[Musique]
quelle est la dernière chose dont tu te
souviens
dany nous satisfaire si tu as survécu
c'est parce que tu n'es pas une jeune
fille ordinaire tu n'es plus seul
plus maintenant savez-vous ce gain de
temps l'un d'eux vous souhaite raconter
sa première fois j'avais 13 ans je
maîtrisais plus rien j'en sais rien j'ai
paniqué il eu des baisers c'est ma
copine gelé brûlés vifs il y en a j'ai
tué 18 personnes une par pays
[Musique]
on n'est pas dans un hôpital on est en
cash
j'ai des quelque chose
un truc qu'elle voulait pas que je vois
on
je crois pas qu'on soit là pour quérir
cet endroit fait resurgir tu es plus
grande peur ils te les faire vivre
jusqu'à ce qu'elle te tue on peut s'en
sortir
ensemble
[Musique]